[Music]
anyway um lana rhodes
tugging off
hundreds of thousands of fans okay so
here's the uh let me see if i can find
this actual comment real quick nfts are
good man they're definitely a good idea
you hear the stuff about uh ice poseidon
doing the same thing exactly yeah i saw
that i saw
part of the video yeah i commend coffee
for going in on going in on his ass yeah
he really went in on his ass yeah went
in on his ass
okay so basically the story is lana
rhodes same thing started an nft project
and they're all like little images of
her i don't know you know she was
touting the same [ __ ] it's like it's
gonna be more than just a
discord and we're gonna do this and
there's a road map and all the [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] that they all have that they
never end up doing so then like recently
the main wallet well she made she made a
million and a half basically the way
that these nfts work is if you set up
the mint you set it up with your main
wallet and all the money that people use
to mint these nfts goes to your wallet
yeah so there's a million and a half in
there right now that she made in one day
from people
doing these and then like a week later
she closed down the discord because it
was too negative
there's too many negative comments sure
and coffee like made a funny point he's
like if you go in there it's literally
all sims i checked out this discord you
can't imagine a bigger simp army these
guys were not negative one of them even
got like a tattoo of the project logo on
them before it rugged and like the
funniest part about it is that people
are still like
when when someone like that sends a
message in the discord like what the
[ __ ] she took all of our money like we
should be pissed yeah someone replies
and goes hey man she said not to be
negative let's not be naked up here so
that she comes back
oh
okay so this i think highlights a very
interesting aspect of
nfts which is it's two things right like
for some people it's that parasocial
[ __ ] but the other part of it is
like that sort of gambling like vice
aspect which is like no matter what
people will still do [ __ ] that's bad for
them do you get what i'm saying like
that person who like bought the nft
and it's like convinced himself like no
we need to associate yeah it's like it's
just that like weird mechanism some
people have like gambling is the most
immediate comparison i make yeah where
people are like this is [ __ ] bad but
like if i sit and play enough like larry
will give me my money back yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying is the same thing
we were talking about last week with
like when you're getting scammed yeah
it's like every part of your brain is
like no we're fine yeah you're not dumb
enough to get scammed yeah it couldn't
be you yeah like just just scrub through
and see if you can find the screenshot
of the discord message from the guy with
the baby because it's really no uh yeah
maybe that's it oh yeah this is this is
after the fact so someone said how do
you want us to keep it respectful while
like the whole it's basically like she
ran off with our money yeah doesn't mean
you can't be respectful i will not
tolerate anyone here using foul language
hate discrimination or any rules being
broken from the original rule sets like
dude i love mods man mods they do their
job you know you hire a mod they're
gonna stick to it he stole over a
million dollars from you guys yeah but
you know what he got he got don't swear
please yeah he got his mod privileges so
out of all that even though he got his
[ __ ] money ran off with he's like
still a mod yeah exactly we have lana
rhodes discard so yeah yeah i moderated
the discord you know it's supposed to be
sort of defunct but i keep it running
yep it's just you know it's one of the
many discords i run exactly and no hate
or discrimination or swearing of any
kind in there nope i'll tell you use one
bad word and i'll be there laying down
the law
dude that's gonna be that first thing
you run into in a bar in like 10 years
and they're like
you know man it's kind of like uh you
know i i ran discord servers for like 10
years yeah like
oh god yeah man i mean like guys lana
rhodes um lana del rey's
um diplos
just crazy stuff you see in there man
yeah i had a lot of recipes remember
that whole thing yeah i mean that was
all basically on my on my back
all those people you know you know it's
just like i think a lot of people
underestimate what mods have to do man
how sad is this this message right here
read that go show her some love let's
prove we are not toxic she can still
save us
yeah yeah these are lonely people
just go back i'm like
a couple minutes or so scammed 6 000
people
6 000 people
that's there it is right there i spent
what i can't lose spent four thousand
dollars on total i had six thousand
dollars man i'm left with 2k only no job
and have a two-year-old son if only
someone bought my christmas lana oh god
oh it hurts me
it hurts me i mean it just makes only
someone would buy my christmas lana it
just makes you wonder if at some point
laws get passed and then they do it in
like some retroactive way and like
coffee is just documented all this awful
[ __ ] yeah there's a lawsuit now uh i
mean there's plenty of lawsuits i'm sure
but one of them right now is against
safe moon and jake paul and everyone who
promoted safe mode they're all named in
the lawsuit ah
i mean it doesn't necessarily make it
illegal but no but if it's i don't know
how that works well it's one of those
things where like if a judgment happens
and it's negative then you can use that
as fuel to go start another lawsuit and
it's like that was deemed illegal this
case is very similar and then it just
sort of starts to yeah spiral but you
know good for her she's gonna get
another car and that's what's important
exactly yeah she'll get another ferrari
that's what she's already worth like oh
yeah okay so this is crazy so miyamotova
is another porn star she's also a twitch
streamer and stuff like that yeah he
like makes a lot of content yep um
so
she basically said in the same discord i
think good morning i chatted to crypto
something about my nft lana isn't
interested in continuing mainly because
she fell she felt part of her discord
community was cruel and didn't want to
have
to look at the comments okay that's why
she shut it down because you don't have
to look at the she like she was even in
the discord in the first place like it
wasn't someone running the discord from
her account
do you think she ever even like opened
no didn't have that [ __ ] on her phone
exactly she still asked how to pronounce
it die score discord sorry so then mia
says i'm still gonna be releasing
mine separate from whoever ran this one
anyone who is whitelisted will be sent
the new one let me know what you think
this wasn't my plan so it won't happen
overnight blah blah and there's like 5
000 reactions to that message of people
that clearly like want to be on the
white list it's like have you not
learned
it's just dude
some people it doesn't matter like they
are gonna get rinsed which is sad it's
the same [ __ ] as a casino the only
difference is like a casino's like kind
of hard to get to you know but this like
this hits like two aspects of that but
like this this is like a casino if
you walked into a casino and there was a
roulette table with like 5 000 numbers
instead of yeah yeah whatever there is
yeah how many numbers are on a roulette
table 50 100 50. 12 12. yeah is it 50
40.
i think it goes down to the 40s 40s okay
whatever so you walk into a roulette
table and there's like 5 000 numbers
yeah and then and lana rose is standing
there yeah being like come here come no
no no no no no no come play you could
win no it's the lana rhodes casino and
this guy kryptosis is running the
roulette table and he's like dude you
guys are gonna win big yeah yeah no but
it's lana too she's there's like videos
of her or something like that like come
to the lanarosa casino and win big yeah
that's what i mean it's her casino and
then when kurtosis runs the ball
right when it's about to land he picks
it up off the thing he goes oh sorry and
he rakes all the money yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like what i thought the ball
was gonna it's like oh yeah it's a rule
of the game the ball doesn't land we
only let it we only let it land
sometimes yeah yeah that's on the road
map you should have read that when you
came into the casino yeah we only saw
video monitors of lana's ass well no
it's there yeah yeah you just gotta wait
wait see look look and then look at she
look it she fires it out of her ass
right there it's just a quick frame
where it goes and then it flows away
yeah
nfcs are good though like yeah
nfts are a good thing
yeah they're sick they're definitely the
future